foreign
[Music]
rebirth has released its second full
trailer and finally we have all the five
cardio that are stated to fight the
Gamera throughout the duration of the
series the five of them are Gauss jaiga
zigra gyron and finally virus we will
showcase clips of the trailer in this
video while at the same time tell you
about the origins powers and sizes of
these enemy kaju of Gamera so let's get
to it
let's start with Gauss in the original
show a series of Gamera films the
origins of Gauss were not definitively
explained it was discovered living in a
large cave however in the heisei trilogy
its Origins were given a backstory they
were the result of genetic engineering
by ancient atlanteans who sought to
create a genetically perfect organism
possibly as a weapon however these
asexually reproducing creatures began
breeding out of control and turned on
their creators the Atlantis then created
Gamera as a lost ditch effort to stop
the gaos but their civilization was
destroyed ultimately too late Gauss is
an Adept flyer capable of sustained
flight due to its bat-like wings it can
move at Great speeds and Agility through
the air one of the most iconic and
devastating abilities is its heat ray
emitted from its large glowing eyes this
heat ray can cause extensive destruction
melting buildings and burn through
almost anything it also has an
impressive regenerative ability allowing
it to heal to heal wounds quickly it can
also emiss a powerful Sonic Screech that
can cause destruction and disorient its
opponents
number two Jagger this is a giant
monster and a Kaiju from the film Gamera
vs jaiga she is an ancient creature with
powerful projectile quills a heat ray
and a stinger that can lay eggs inside
her opponents Jagger's Origins is not
definitively explained in the film but
she is depicted as a malevolent and
destructive force seeking to obtain the
devil's whistle a device that can end
unbearable rain sounds causing her pain
in Gamera super monster it is an alien
Kaiju so this kaju possesses a variety
of deadly weapons and Powers she can
emit a magnetic Ray from her head which
burns anything in its and damages
gamera's eardrums with high frequency
sound waves she can fire solid saliva
missiles needles of solidified saliva
from her nose Corners to impale and
immobilize her enemies her vampiric
tactic involves using her Stinger to
implant parasitic young into her
opponents draining their blood
additionally Jagger has magnetic circles
on her palms and feet with immense
suction power enabling her to grab grab
and throw objects over long distances
number three zigra in the original movie
zigra is depicted as an alien Creature
From A Distant planet where fish feed on
people he travels to Earth in a
spaceship with the intent of destroying
Gamera and enslaving the human race in
Dark Horse Gamera Comics azigra is
reimagined as a biological weapon that
escaped from the planet called brookmark
and invaded Earth with the same
intentions of enslaving humanity and
using them as a food source zigra has an
array of powers including flight with
its fins jumping over long distances and
transitioning between land and Aquatic
forms it possesses three different light
rays a cell activity suspension beam
that halts human selectivity a fourth
dimensional beam that transfers matter
in and out and an earthquake inducing
beam causing devastating explosions and
earthquakes ziggurat also has a
tri-colored beam attack combining all
these three however zigra is extremely
weak to sunlight due to its origins in
dark ocean depths and is also highly
susceptible to fire
number four gyron in Gamera vs gyron of
1969 gyron is depicted as one of the
many monsters spawn when the electronic
brain controlling the Planet Terror when
Haywire leading to alterations in the
environment as a result garon became one
of Tara's strongest and most dangerous
monsters garon lived in a special Hangar
under the stream at the Terran base and
was Guided by mind control device used
by two brain eating space women gyron
possesses a massive blade on its
forehead a hundred times harder than
Diamond which can reflect and cut
through powerful attacks like spacegow
supersonic scalpel and gamera's shell
the blade can also produce vibrations
for increased attacking power and
enables gyron to burrow underground as a
secondary attack garon uses sharp
shurikens stored in its head to induce
severe bleeding and render opponents
unconscious however gyron's skin over
the area where he launches his shurkins
is weak and Gamera exploits this
weakness by detonating a missile through
leading to gyron's demise
and number five virus in the original
movie Gamera vs virus virus originates
as an expedition force of aliens from
planet virus to come to Earth with the
intention of conquering it in a dark
horse coming series however virus is
reimagined as a creature cloned from
gao's DNA by Dr Greta Carbone they both
use the same strategy of kidnapping
children to exploit gamera's weakness
his kindness and manipulate him through
a brainwave control device to cause
destruction in Japan virus has a
cephalopod slash octopus look he has six
prehensile tentacles lined with suction
cups and can easily restrain opponents
the pedal-like protrusions on his head
can form into a spear like tip capable
of penetrating gamera's shell virus can
swim and fly positioning his body
horizontally for both movements in a
Dark Horse Comics virus can fight blasts
of electricity and overtake the mind of
his creator Greta carborn bending her to
his will however virus is susceptible to
being frozen and gamero ultimately
defeats him in that movie by him up to
the atmosphere freezing him solid and
causing him to explode upon impact with
the ocean below
so those are the origins powers and
sizes of the different kaijus that will
be seen in Gamera rebirth well not
essentially Origins from that Universe
well from other continuities that say
anyway I hope you have enjoyed watching
this video do hit the like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos like this here on this
channel take care fam